Los Angeles Clippers belong to us it's
our team so we will repossess the
Clippers from mrs. sterling hi I'm
Alexis Garcia with reason TV and here in
LA anger over racist remarks made by
Clippers owner Donald sterling have
resulted in a protest outside the
Staples Center before game five of the
western conference finals the longtime
Clippers owner was handed a lifetime ban
by the NBA after racist remarks made an
a private conversation were made public
by TMZ this decision by the NBA raises
questions on how private thoughts affect
public life in an increasingly
transparent society and the role that
market forces play in responding to
racism and other repugnant beliefs we're
here to ask fans what they think about
sterling and the league's reaction to it
don't like black people it's like 12
years of slavery or roots or the butler
that's what's wrong with that hidden you
know it always comes out no matter what
its gonna come out one day and it came
out in a very wrong way my son he loves
basketball and when he heard I heard and
to hear these comments that was really
hurtful towards those comments touch
home they were directed towards my
ethnicity but those type of comments
directed towards any ethnicity are wrong
looking at the NBA's reaction and you
also see some of the reaction from the
sponsors like Kia like Virgin America
pulling their money do you think that
the market acted reacted appropriately
to his racism well you know if you don't
nip these fires these look flurries that
could become fire in the bud it could
grow to be even worse than what it is I
think the market did react i think there
needs to be further a reaction i mean if
you're gonna be in a position of power
you've got to be prepared
to be responsible for the influence you
have on other people you know I think
the people here and the sponsors are
probably still behind the team and the
coach they're just not going to they
have to do something to show a stand
against early we know that Donald
Sterling's a racist but do you think
there are other things like police
brutality like the war on drugs that are
a bigger problem for the black unity of
course the LA County Sheriff's what was
that back in December 18 of them got
arrested for abuse in the prison and
they beat up visitors and then they are
all have felonies what is that that's
Donna stone is a penny in the bucket of
what's really happy the Warren drug
that's a specific example of how
institutionalized racism takes place
with the war on drugs is targeted
towards the inner cities how do those
drugs get there in fact if you look at
the statistics who want you utilizes
more drugs it's not the african-american
it's not the community and watts and in
Compton in fact it's the suburbs we are
about capitalism we are about starting
our own businesses and building our own
businesses a lot of people need to start
talking about OPM other people's money
and Elsie is an S corporation these are
the ideas in Z be allocated within the
group of the people there is going to be
a vote of the ownership three-fourths of
them have to agree for him to sell the
team but even if he is forced to sell
he's gonna have some sort of profit from
that is that a satisfactory ending oh
the money that he receives that's
besides the point the fact is that when
these players sweat on this floor when
the fans spend their money for
concessions or spend their money for the
tickets in fact it won't be going to him
no longer but as of today when these
players play tonight that's sweat every
ounce of that swept that's being dripped
onto that floor it's going in direct
consideration and tours mr. Sterling's
wallet well all that being said reading
for the Clippers Oh 100% we're winning
in a few in about a few hours we'll be
celebrating who are you rooting for
tonight
no we put a home team you already know
I'm a Laker fan but I wrote for the
local team as well